[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et le gaz vous venez d'écrire un livre
sur l'air post-colonial notamment en
Afrique plus principalement en Afrique
que vous avez appelé les bons
ressentiments qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
les bons ressentiments le ressentiment
est un peu l'emprise du bourreau sur sa
victime emprise à la remorque en quelque
sorte de laquelle se trouve écrasé tous
les affects de la victime et donc dès
qu'on rentre dans cette logique très
pernicieuse dans ce cercle très vicieux
c'est que on est dans la réaction dans
la plainte dans l'incapacité à
s'affranchir d'une forme d'humiliation
et puis de son saut qui a posé comme ça
sur la victime et donc c'est entériné un
statut de victime éternelle et donc qui
ne crée pas les ressources en quelque
sorte ni l'initiative ni l'espion
d'entreprise à partir du moment où on
entre dans cette logique là on entérine
pour de bon ça défaites et donc appelez
ça les bons ressentiments c'est de jouer
justement sur une fièvre qui est
mondiale qui n'est pas d'ailleurs que
dans les relations postes coloniales ou
africaines on est dans une épreuve entre
l'Occident et le reste du monde si vous
me permettez pression exactement moi
j'avais fait une tribu une à
Ouest-France ou je parlais de la
revanche des damnés de la terre
c'est-à-dire le sentiment d'expression
qui est le titre d'un livre de Franz
fannon exactement que je trafic autre en
tout petit peu l'idée que beaucoup de
populations qui se sont sentis pendant
très longtemps exclu à la fois des
fesses du monde de tout ce que le monde
a produit comme richesse comme espace de
dialogue comme espace de discussion
d'intéressant de voyage tous ces gens là
qui ont été marqués en quelque sorte par
cette forme d'infériorisation et de
cette inégalité qui frappe encore très
très fort oui ont tendance à jeter
parfois le bébé avec l'eau du bain et à
vouloir renverser le système dans ce
qu'on a appelé dans les expressions
diverses
dégagisme et puis au fond de cela
ce sentiment de ressentiment d'une forme
d'humiliation tu qui refait surface et
dont la fièvre est comme ça parfois
assez terrible et on a une autrice
française une philosophe qui s'appelle
Cynthia Fleury
du ressentiment qui est une monographie
formidable ce sentiment là et en le
réutilisant dans mon titre c'est montrer
que aussi loin monte en fait les cris
d'émancipation il y a encore des liens
d'un interdépendance d'interdépendance
et donc il faut aller à la racine
justement de ce malaise là c'est
pourquoi j'ai appelé mon livre les bons
ressentiments alors pourquoi bon
oui mais parce que l'époque l'époque
cultive ressentiment lui donnant une
vertu quasiment c'est ça c'est ça et
puis dans le ressentiment il n'y a pas
tout acheté parce que ce que dit la
victime de ce qu'elle a subi n'est pas
quelque chose de contestable c'est ce
qu'elle en fait qui est le problème donc
les bons ressentiments on peut avoir
d'ailleurs de bons ressentiments qui
sont parfaitement justifiés par exemple
lesquels dire que la structure coloniale
et c'est survivants et sa manière de se
pérenniser par des biais un peu tordus
par une certaine forme d'opacité
d'horizontalité existe encore et qu'il
faut
repenser les échanges et c'est d'en
sortir c'est quelque chose de
parfaitement recevable donc une pensée
décoloniale réelle dans sa perspective
ancienne qui ne tombe pas dans les mains
d'un activisme rapide qui ne cherche que
des ennemis c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel et moi je m'inscris plutôt
dans cette dans cette mouvance là c'est
des coloniales réelles pas dans son
expression très panique accusatrice que
l'on voit en France qui me paraît
problématique et donc c'est pourquoi
rechercher une vérité réparer les
failles de l'histoire me paraît
important et dans cette mesure là la
notion de bon ressentiment peut avoir
des échos est-ce que vous faites une
différence entre
anti colonialisme et des colonialisme
alors ces sujets sont très techniques
alors anticholonialisme ça a toujours
existé toute colonisation produit dès
les origines
son rejet
par définition donc l'anticononialisme a
toujours existé on dépenseur qui ont été
des acteurs majeurs dans des
colonisation n'ont jamais utilisé
l'étiquette des coloniales ce qui arrive
récemment c'est une pensée décoloniales
avec ses ancrages ces perspectives
historiques avec son épistémologie sa
théorie avec d'ailleurs des origines que
l'on retrouve dans les pays
sud-américains et donc c'est cette
pensée aussi qui voyage qui va aussi
avoir des tonalités des expressions dans
les universités américaines avec des
termes parfois des prix acides
on les pure plutôt de tout ce qui de
tout ce qui gêne alors si on prend le
parti de ne partir que sur des slogans
des exceptions rapides oui on est pure
mais ces sujets sont infiniment
complexes il y a des choses qui sont
parfaitement à recevoir et des
extrapolations alors c'est ces
extrapolations qui sont très très
commodes pour la poudrière des réseaux
sociaux ou pour la pensée difficile de
l'époque ou très souvent on parle de
racisées on parle de wokism on parle de
cancer les cultures et ainsi de suite
c'est réalité on les expressions réelles
l'intérêt d'une pensée réelle c'est
d'aller les explorer les évaluer pour ce
qu'elles sont de ne pas tomber dans la
nature de ne pas tomber dans la
disqualification facile de terme qui ont
des résonances par ailleurs moi je ne
suis pas tout à fait pour justement
l'épuration pour justement la propreté
pour un hygiénisme moral je ne pense pas
que ce soit productif mais conçoit de la
même manière aussi sensible aux quêtes à
la recherche d'une inclusion réelle à
une pluralité en universel qui embrasse
justement tous les horizons du monde je
pense que c'est quelque chose aussi que
je trouve essentiel et donc dans ce
débat là il ne faut pas venir en arbitre
tranché de façon hémiplégique avec des
amnésies volontaires il faut venir
offrir la chance du dialogue de la
complexité et de la nuance et il me
semble ce sont ces notions là qui sont
écrasées par les débats actuels alors
dans les bons ressentiments vous avez
une expression une formule qui est très
intéressante qui consiste à dire en gros
les jeunes générations se voient
tellement peu d'avenir qu'elle se
réfugie dans les remugues du passé ça
veut dire quoi parce que ce passé en
gros c'est un passé qu'elle critique
justement y compris celui de leurs aînés
c'est-à-dire de ceux qui ont été les
acteurs de la décolonisation la
tentation
nihiliste elle est bien présente dans la
jeunesse africaine qui accable autant
ses dirigeants que la structure
coloniale ce qui est intéressant
justement dans cette logique justement
de destitution des idoles et puis dans
le refuge justement de se mettre sur la
tutelle de structure que l'on pense
gangrené et condamné pour de bons se
réfugier dans un passé imaginaire dans
l'illusion d'honneur dans l'existence
d'un parchemin qu'il suffirait en
quelque sorte de dépister pour embrasser
la prospérité c'est un autre mythe c'est
fantasme qui entretenu pour le coup par
les rentiers d'une certaine forme de
décolonisation militante qui ne servent
finalement que les rentiers et pas
forcément l'ordre collectif et ces
jeunes aussi dans leur acte de
destitution de tout ce qui a préexister
attaque les responsables gouvernantes
mais les attaquent pas pour leurs échecs
ils les attaquent pour intelligence
supposer avec l'ennemi occidentale ils
ont été des collaborateurs
et c'est là où la délégation de toute
forme de responsabilité de ces acteurs
là produit un monde finalement aux
personnes les responsable de rien ou le
coupable presque tout trouvé c'est la
colonisation et sa matrice il ne s'agit
nullement d'exonérer la colonisation
justement de ce qu'est la produit comme
violence comme humiliation comme
survivant mais ne pas tout lui prêter ou
tout lui imputer parce que pour le coup
c'est oublier que les Africains de
manière générale ne sont pas des acteurs
passifs de l'histoire toute modernité
est une co-construction et que désigner
des victimes ne doit pas aboutir en
quelque sorte à
des responsabiliser d'autres et tenir
les deux bouts dans ce dans ce registre
là est très très compliqué et chez des
jeunes africains très souvent
il se heurte à une réalité on manque
d'horizon c'est à dire ils ne sont pas
absorbés par le tissu économique et
social chez eux tout est assez bouché et
au plus fort des discours sur la
décolonisation qui ont comme fief la
diaspora au même moment les jeunes
africains ont envie pour beaucoup de
quitter le continent pour aller parfois
un homme voilà le paradoxe voilà le
paradoxe où nous mène justement tout
toutes ces périodes là qui n'ont jamais
véritablement diagnostiquer les choses
très très finement et qui n'ont pas posé
justement de paradigme émancipateur réel
parce que les discours plaintifs créent
les conditions
d'accusation d'un bourreau auquel on
reste encore tout à fait lié c'est
pourquoi encore une fois j'utilisais le
terme les bons ressentiments comment on
en sort de cette éternel face à face
entre bien le coloniser et celui qu'on
accuse tous les mots c'est à dire le
colon sort toutes ces choses là touchent
à des affects touchent à des blessures
profondes il me paraît important de ne
pas les minimiser et les prendre en
considération la dynamique la dynamique
d'empathie et pour le coup très très
important mais il faut reprendre le sens
de l'initiative de ne pas être justement
à la remorque pour naître finalement bon
que pour la réaction voilà la réaction
qui avalisée la suprématie de l'autre
dans son agenda auquel on vient
finalement répondre et réparer cette
histoire là si tu es les responsables
extérieurs et les responsables endogènes
avoir une culture du débat beaucoup plus
pluriel ne pas songer à une certaine
forme d'existence d'ilodore ou
d'identité pure comprendre que toutes
les sociétés africaines sont des
mélanges sont des juxtaposition sont des
fédérations d'identité en quelque sorte
comprendre ces dynamiques et aller
chercher partout où le savoir peut être
porteur d'échapper il doit pareil que
c'est le chantier et ce chantier là il
faut qu'il s'affranchisse justement de
la frange de la plainte perpétuelle qui
elle enferme dans le ressentiment et
donc en sortie c'est reprendre le
discours sur son histoire pas par des
narrations comme on l'appelle des
narratifs narratifs c'est le nom
narratifs sont éloignés parfois du réel
il faut oser affronter le réel et puis
l'enchanter par le rêve par l'espoir et
surtout par une ingénerie économique et
culturelle il me semble que sur ces
aspects-là le bât blesse par moment
alors qu'il y a tous les éléments je
veux dire sur le plan culturel on peut
pas dire que jamais l'Afrique a autant
rayonné sur le plan culturel il y a une
infusion aujourd'hui de toutes les
cultures s'il y a pas qu'une seule
culture de toutes les cultures
africaines dans les goûts et les modes
de vie
mondialisés je dirais
alors là vous avez dit voilà par
l'innovation par l'initiative l'Afrique
les Afrique peuvent se sortir de ce
ressentiment éternel mais il y a aussi
de l'autre côté ben notamment les pays
anciennement colonisateurs qui peuvent
aussi changer d'attitude est-ce que vous
estimez par exemple que Emmanuel Macron
il a eu quelques initiatives notamment
le sommet franco-africain de Montpellier
ou pour la première fois il a pas invité
des chefs d'État mais il a invité des ce
qu'on appelle de la société civile qui
était étroitement quand même
sélectionnés on va dire est-ce que ça a
changé quelque chose est-ce que ça
change quelque chose alors vous y étiez
peut-être d'ailleurs à Montpellier moche
n'y était pas il y a il y a quelque
chose d'important de ce que dans ce que
vous avez dit sur l'existence d'une
richesse culturelle qui n'a jamais qui
n'a jamais disparu et là toujours été là
elle n'a été ni moins connu quand même
voilà elle a été ni qu'à la défaveur
d'un récit
par le manque de jonction entre le
discours et les faits la prétention les
tensions et la réalité de ces relations
là donc il y a toujours une certaine
forme de verticalité et malgré les
bonnes intentions qui sont notables que
je salue convier toute une jeunesse
africaine
qui ne cesse d'accablir Paris
au frais de son bourreau pour qu'elle
demande des redditions de compte à des
gouvernements qu'elle n'a pas élu c'est
ton enfance complet
c'est leurs interlocuteurs s'il y a
quelque chose qui ne va pas chez eux
ils s'intéresse à eux ils leur disent
mais considéré que Paris est encore le
centre
décisionnaire du discours et du compte
discours que Paris a un pouvoir
décisionnaire sur les destinats
Africains c'est un mythe c'est un mythe
parce que la France n'est ni une
solution en Afrique ni un problème alors
c'est très compliqué à entendre pour les
ambitions empathique française très
compliqué à comprendre pour les
africains mais c'est aussi simple que
cela le rayonnement de la France
actuellement en Afrique est en train de
s'effondrer les parts de marché
économique sont en train de s'effondrer
la réalité c'est que on est dans une
recomposition totale qui n'a pas
commencé qu'aujourd'hui dans la
perspective est très très ancienne et
donc les bonnes volontés doivent être
date on ne peut pas encore en tant que
pays avoir une politique africaine oui
ça veut rien dire ça ça veut rien dire
et puis c'est dur c'est mal perçu et
puis la prétention allait faire le vide
ça rappelle tristement les tonalités de
Jules Ferry allez civilisée des gens et
donc c'est réminiscences de l'histoire
nourrissent encore des colères qui n'ont
pas besoin d'ailleurs d'être nourris
parce qu'elles existent parce que ce
ressentiment de base existe et donc à ce
problème structurel se rajoutent des
problèmes conjonctuels des problèmes
conjoncturels c'est ce qu'on voit soit
en Ukraine dans le monde actuellement ou
justement d'autres puissances à l'affût
dans la prédation du continent se disent
qu'il y a une place à prendre quitte à
mordre les mollets de ce qu'il y avait
le pré carré et c'est ce qui se passe au
Burkina c'est ce que vous dites avec
effectivement la rivière masse ou le
retour en masse parce qu'il faut pas
l'oublier quand même que les Russes qui
étaient jadis ou naguère soviétique
avait aussi une influence énorme sur le
continent Afric donc là vous êtes en
train de parler des Russes à travers les
milices Wagner mais on peut parler des
chinois mais on peut parler des Turcs
mais on peut parler des Iraniens mais on
peut parler des Israéliens aussi enfin
c'est une terre qui est extrêmement
convoitée c'est
c'est le continent c'est en slack
peut-être que c'est le continent du 21e
siècle c'est pas si c'est le continent
du développement mais c'est le continent
de la de la conquête alors c'est c'est
une espèce de farce House mais c'est
c'est triste pour nos continents des
Nets peut-être
comme une proie
il y a un livre qui a été moi important
pour
pour ma formation intellectuelle le
discours sur le colonialisme d'aimer ses
airs ah et Aimé Césaire c'est pour
beaucoup voilà je crois aussi je crois
nous sommes nos pays
antillais et Aimé Césaire disait que
l'aventure coloniale était une aventure
aussi de prédation c'est des économies
interagonistes qui se trouve à un obligé
d'exporter leur querelle dans des terres
nouvelles pour et c'est exactement ce
qui se passe après aujourd'hui c'est à
dire des économies antagonistes en lutte
qui fondent comme ça sur comme des
fauves sur le continent parce que tout
le récit capitaliste est un récit
opportuniste toutes les projections
démographiques que moi j'appelle du
démographique c'est à dire un récit
porteur pour essayer uniquement de
vendre c'est ce qui est en train de
passer sur le continent au moment où la
France est en train de reculer d'autres
s'installent très très confortablement
et
la prise d'initiative le récit sur soi
avoir une certaine forme de souveraineté
sur ces produits et en train de
disparaître et là pour le coup la France
est un ennemi commode parce que pour le
coup elle change de discours sa
verticalité en fin de la casser elle
donne des gages des bonnes volontés mais
vu que historiquement elle a été
l'ennemi
elle a été justement la matrice
intellectuelle et que jusqu'à présent
elle reste justement le centre des
décisions de l'édition du lectorat du
réseau institutionnel et culturel oui ça
crée les conditions de ressentiment à
côté il y a toute une force justement
prédatrice qui est en train d'aller sur
le continent sans état d'âme et résultat
des courses aujourd'hui c'est à dire
tout ce qui marche dans un pays comme le
Sénégal n'est pas sénégalais
donc la richesse c'est et expatriée en
quelque sorte et c'est une richesse qui
vient beaucoup des pays du Golfe
notamment mais c'est un monde
multipolaire il va partout il va en
Chine comme vous l'avez dit il va en
Russie très timidement parce que les
Russes historiquement n'ont pas eu de
relation économique privilégiées mais on
oublie très souvent dans la donnée
quelque chose d'essentiel voilà la
guerre froide
et même avant c'est-à-dire en plein
développement du maxisme qui a élu des
fiefs dans beaucoup de Capitals
africaines dans Dakar beaucoup de
dirigeants africains ont été formés en
URSS à l'université Patrice et cette
forme de force intellectuelle
a toujours tenu ce discours anti
colonial et une fois au pouvoir cet
échec n'a pas été sondé ou évalué donc
on est dans des réminiscences de
l'histoire qui sont cruelles des formes
de répétition et vous connaissez sans
doute la formule l'histoire se répète
toujours deux fois la première fois en
tragédie à la deuxième fois en face et
là la seule différence c'est que la
farce est aussi tragique et donc on est
dans ce on est dans ce dans cette
situation là où on ne s'embarrasse même
plus de regarder les faits c'est à dire
l'effet deviennent embarrassants
c'est-à-dire des discours il y a des
idéologies il y a des postures il y a
des regards qui sont commodes parce que
taper sur l'Occident c'est la garantie
de recruter des admirateurs faciles sur
le continent alors que justement la
réalité de la présence française n'a
rien à voir avec le temps de focard et
le temps des colonies
Afrique du général de Gaulle et de
Georges Pompidou dans votre livre vous
avez cette formule qui me paraît très
intéressante
vous dites l'islam
et l'aimant
rassembleur de l'anti colonialisme
est-ce que vous estimez que cette Islam
qui part en droit et notamment dans le
sel c'est souvent transformé en
islamisme et bien effectivement ça
servit d'armes d'une certaine façon
intellectuelle d'idéologie contre
les anciens colonisateurs à tout le mois
un argument fédérateur
c'est à dire quand on regarde moi j'ai
appelé dans mon livre le chapitre la
généalogie du sentiment anti-francier
antioxydantal
en essayant de voir la donner un peu
multicosal de la faire et donc j'en
reviens un peu à l'islam c'est à dire
quand on regarde
les interventions françaises dans le
temps long en Afrique il y a des fiefs
qui sont des fièvres qui sont restés
dans les mémoires il y a l'Algérie dans
le récit qui a été fait de la contre
violence coloniale l'Islam a joué un
rôle fondateur parce qu'il a fédérés
contre justement il offre une
alternative une autre récit un kit
explicatif du monde et un kit politique
qui était pour beaucoup une forme
d'identité ancrée alors que même quand
on regarde dans la perspective très
ancienne cette Islam là n'a pas une
simultanéité avec les populations
forcément qu'elle prétend défendre à qui
elle prétend offrir justement en horizon
on regarde aussi ce qui se passe en
Algérie dans les années 90 la guerre
avec la guerre civile ainsi de suite
vous regardez ce qui se passe au Sénégal
dans mon pays
c'est à dire il y a un livre de Moriba
Magassouba qui est en journaliste qui a
été à Jeune Afrique qui a les années 80
écrit un livre qui s'appelle Sénégal et
demain les mots là déjà et quand vous
regardez ça déjà déjà dans les années 80
alors que pendant très longtemps on a
considéré que des pays comme le Sénégal
les pays africains en Afrique en Islam
soufi exactement un éclame soufi était
un rempart contre l'avancée du wahabisme
et il y a eu des chocs aussi qui se sont
produits il y a eu la révolution
iranienne voilà qui a aussi eu son son
déflagration avec quelque sorte dans le
monde donc l'islam est devenu une forme
d'identité pour des gens aussi qui
voulaient contester l'ordre
occidental et donc ça ces expressions là
ces ancrage là existent c'est à dire
pour contrer le discours
occidental oui on trouvait commodement
comme on dit mon voilà c'est entité
islamique qui pouvait produire en contre
discours il faut pas oublier que
toute colonisation
produit les conditions d'une forme de
contre-violence et de contrecis et ces
récit là on le trouve partout on peut le
trouver dans le marxisme on peut le
trouver dans l'aNTIC colonialisme on
peut le trouver aussi dans une version
aussi de l'islam et n'oublions pas que
même en Occident les trous qui anglais
ont théorisé l'islamo gauchisme avant
que le terme ne devienne dépréciatif
dans la bouche de beaucoup on entend des
à l'époque qu'il fallait faire une
alliance avec l'islam que le front ne
devait pas découvrir en quelque sorte
l'ennemi l'ennemi qui était l'ennemi
occidentale ça matrice dans laquelle on
mettait à la fois le capitalisme et les
libéralisme et c'est ce que je raconte
comment justement l'usage d'un discours
islamiste a été aussi un argument
fédérateur un argument de poids pour des
populations qui étaient émiettées qui
n'avaient pas forcément les mêmes
origines les mêmes ethnies ni même les
mêmes ascendants spirituelles et
auxquelles justement population auquel
l'islam offrait
comment un horizon une devise une vision
du monde qu'on peut appeler
partiellement la Oumma et dans la Oumma
une fois que le l'unité sera sera
véritablement découverte dans cette
fragilité on verra que c'était une
alliance de circonstance parce que cette
donnée là on la voit aujourd'hui parce
que dans tout ce récit très porteur de
la houma il y a des zones d'ombres qui
ont été très commodément mis sur le
tarte une définition de la houma c'est
le rassemblement des c'est la grande
famille mais les grandes familles
musulmanes la grande famille des grandes
familles musulmanes exactement et il y a
un auteur sénégalais qui s'appelle
Tidiane Diagne qui a écrit justement sur
sur la traite
voilà transsaharienne et justement et
sur un racisme très très fort qui existe
par les pays maghrébins jusqu'à la
manifester
il dit il parle de la traite orientale
et dit qu'elle a été sous regardé
sous-estimé par rapport à ce qui a été
la traite occidentale il parle de
l'empire du Naquet mais de la dynastie
des Saïfs de devoirs de violence mais
encore récemment exemple le plus sans
doute parlant on a eu
le président tunisien
qui a eu qui a libéré les flots racistes
en Tunisie contre les populations
Sud
d'Afrique subsaharienne ainsi de suite
révélant par là justement on vieux front
qui a toujours existé que les luttes
antioxydantes avaient jusqu'à présent
assez maintenu sous silence ou c'est
scellé je sais pas comment il faut dire
mais en tout cas voilà voilà beaucoup de
réalité justement
qui ont eu tendance à être occulté parce
que la récurrence du discours
devait uniquement focaliser la tension
sur le bureau
occidental ça a été entretenu entretenu
aussi d'ailleurs par une partie de la
gauche française anti coloniale parce
que c'est 30 décoloniales elle était
assez confortable alors que plus la
rente monte plus justement cette
popularité existe plus les populations
africaines étaient encore une fois
enferré dans des logiques
d'asservissement
elle gaz quand vous dansez vous dansez
sur quelle musique africaine sur
beaucoup alors je danse sur Tesla Mariam
kidanais elles sont pas nécessairement
d'ensemble toutes les musiques
évidemment mais on peut toujours dans
ces cas
[Musique]
on va continuer à l'écouter puis en même
temps un auteur un écrivain africain que
vous appréciez tout particulièrement à
celui qui m'a marqué que j'ai découvert
sur le tard c'est un écrivain guinéen
qui s'appelle williamsine
parce qu'il a eu un destin un peu
funeste ces étoiles filantes très
talentueux mais qui a été un peu boudé
par la reconnaissance jusqu'à la fin de
sa vie et qui a écrit des bouquins de
l'humour dévastateur et d'une justesse
remarquable merci el gaz merci
[Musique]